in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Keith
and Jennifer are with us merry Christmas
to you Merry Christmas Dave how are you
guys great good where do you live we
live in Nashville
oh we're neighbors then yeah okay very
cool and you drove all the way a couple
of miles in this traffic there's a
holiday traffic out of here anyway
takes forever because we're over here by
this mall to do your debt free scream
how much dad have you paid off we've
paid off eighty three thousand nine
hundred eighty dollars and sixty two
cents love it and how long did that take
you 40 months forty months making what
kind of money during that time um
80 to 120 doing a lot of extra
consulting on the side awesome making
and what do you guys do for a living I'm
an information technology I'm a geek
okay cool and I'm mostly stay-at-home
mom but I do a little bit of corporate
training on the side very good
very cool what kind of debt was the 84
everything we were pretty normal we had
credit cards we had two car loans we had
student loans we had a personal loan we
had mini-blinds
just about anything you can think of you
financed mini-blinds yep
you are Americans without a doubt oh my
goodness Wow so how long have y'all been
married 15 years 15 years so tell me
your story what happened 40 months ago
well 40 months ago she brought the book
into our lives and just you know you
talk about the perfect way to approach
someone about this and she ticked every
single one of them I she was positive
she came to me with with it and kind of
went through the steps and then said you
know would you like to uh to look at it
and I looked at it and it's a pretty
much just all common sense I was kind of
chucked that last call it kind of you
know always cynical so I did mention you
in the past and over I was too smart for
you so sure years ago and after I read
the book realized I wasn't not so so
which book a total money maker the Total
Money Makeover okay very cool so
Jennifer what led you to that we just
had our third child and I think just
things just started building and out
month to month we were realizing that
you know he
kenneth was making a good income but we
had nothing to show for it we would
living paycheck to paycheck and really
had no plan for the future and I think I
just really got scared for not only our
future but mainly for the our kids
future mm-hmm
so the math just quit working and and so
you kind of had to do something it's
like you've been doing and it's really
you didn't get in debt all at once it
was death by a thousand cuts over 15
years wasn't it yeah oh yeah that's
normal anyway and that's not surprising
to hear well congratulations
so how did you do this people are
listening they hear you paid off eighty
four thousand dollars and 40 months
that's over two thousand dollars a month
and you stayed with it over three years
that's a long time to keep your
attention span in this culture how what
are the secrets to getting out of debt
well I mean the budget was definitely
one but I'll just to say we we fell off
the wagon for a short period
well actually we should have been done
way sooner and in the end we were paying
off what three six something amazing
amounts of huge checks to a to a car
loan and we were always listening to the
to your show actually in the debt free
screams and I'm listening to people who
are you know paying off restitution
widows who come in whose husbands died
while paying off debt eighty
five-year-old minute son who recently I
just heard one made a twenty five
thousand and paid off seventy five
thousand mmm-hmm and kind of looked at
and got sick to my stomach at how just
ridiculous my situation was I had
nothing but excuses for not you know
finishing this and getting done and got
back up on the wagon pack in December
and felt sick for nine months and you
know finally back October first for the
first time in nine months about well
yeah yeah we gonna take off that last
car now I love it okay so you got you
had you had kind of a little bit of loss
of emotional enthusiasm but then you got
your second wind and plowed through it's
what it amounts to absolutely yes okay
very cool how did you get the second
wind just listening to the other
debt-free screams is that hearing
hearing debt-free screams and realizing
that there was hearing that I said
people just you know people who have
cancer while they're paying off this
debt I mean and we I hit a deer with no
car I didn't have a good reason
okay Jennifer what do you say the
secrets are I think the biggest secrets
are like a lot of people say the budget
you can't do it without a budget we had
always had a quote unquote budget but
we've never really had a budget until we
started actually putting it on paper and
then went over to every dollar calm
that's when the real difference was made
and then of course being on the same
page we we didn't have a lot of money
fights because we never really talked
about money a lot and so we started
talking about money we had a budget
meeting once a week and we still do and
those two things combined just can't be
beat
yeah tell the people you know when they
when they're starting to fall off the
wagon you're not meeting on the budget
enough because you meet on that budget
you suddenly realize where you're doing
what's going on now and when we're
talking about a budget what you're
saying is is you had a budget before but
then it didn't work this one the
difference is you really did the detail
every dollar had an assignment every
month is that what you mean yes yep
that's a zero-based every dollar budget
idea and when you do that that becomes
your plan and you see you get a sense
attraction don't you like hey we're
gonna be you almost look forward to the
bills coming in the mail seeing around
BAM yeah because you got a plan and
there you don't dread everything there's
always a sense of dread around money
when you're out of control so well
congratulations you guys very very well
done now who's with you to do your
debt-free scream we have Anna who's 11
and then we have some more around here
they're coming into the picture okay man
this is a little guy right here is
Joseph William and Joshua Anna all right
a very cool beautiful family ready to go
have the little guys been practicing
yeah and they were instrumental in
helping us especially during the last
stretch of this they put up with a lot
of scrambled eggs for dinner and beans
and rice we we literally can't say beans
and rice in our house that's a cuss word
now all right Kenneth and Jennifer and
family a tea
four thousand dollars paid off in 40
months making 80 to 120 a year the time
has come counted down
let's hear a debt free scream
absolutely fabulous
now that's one you wanted to see on TV
those little guys screaming I'm debt
free they did a great job you know why
most people don't win they don't bother
you have to bother it to be intentional
never again as American Express gonna
call my house and ask my wife why she
would stay with a man that won't pay his
bills